Few months ago, Lindsay and I flew all the way to New York
to work with one of my favorite beauty brands, lineage.
And the ones that have been around for a while
know how much I love their lip sleeping mask,
how much I use it. So when they wanted to shoot me for it,
I obviously had to say yes.
Made it to set bright and early.
Got a good look at all the outfits,
and then we headed into glam doing makeup,
nails, and hair.
So I got dressed,
we did all the touch UPS we needed before heading on set.
After photographing the first outfit,
we realized that we needed an outfit change,
so I picked this little Barbie inspired dress.
We shot the lip sleeping mask in the midnight Minis.
Found this aura reading person on set,
and she read my aura, which was so fun.
I loved seeing my little aura picture.
Also had some lunch, did touch UPS,
and then it was time to shoot all the social stuff.
Any TikToks, any story posts.
I also always love seeing all the planning
that goes on behind the scenes.
I couldn't help myself
but try all the lip sleeping masks while shooting,
but once all that was done, we wrapped.